so for those of you that don't know I
have been doing YouTube for about a year
and I got a million subscribers in a
year uh 1.2 you know if we're going to
be exact and we talk about a lot of
controversial topics and we talk about a
lot of issues that specifically affect
men and in this show I just get a lot of
flack from bitter women honestly because
we talk about things from the men's
point of view a lot of times and we'll
talk about things that specifically
affect men so like for example men only
get custody of their children 10 of the
time ninety percent of alimony alimony
cases are where men are paying men make
up the majority of suicides et cetera
Etc